drum roll please the date is finally set
for Mariah Carey's highly anticipated
guest spot on Empire it will be October
the 5th it will be epic you know the
Mariah rookie are gonna be quite
effective it'll be bananas but I'm Carly
Steele here now and you caught up with
me while she was in full vacation oh I
certainly did and it was every bit as
glamorous as you'd expect cruising the
Mediterranean and a stunning yacht but
Mariah did admit she keeps the glam
gourmet in Italy to a minimum to stay
fabulous and those find out bikinis I
just want to talk about how hot you look
you look that's so very nice it's like
this is a new part of my ensemble
collection visit but you know it's for
bathing suits it's for HSN more time
everyone wants to know how they can look
like you like can you least give us one
tip as to how you maintain this
discipline when you're abroad I just
have to eat the same boring food all the
time and I was trying to get in some
water workouts as a trainer this year
but boring food can be nice I know you
love tuna tartare
well I got to be sick of that that I had
to move on
it's Mariah's world Richardson I love it
lounging aboard her private yacht off
the coast of Capri
well fiance billionaire James Packer
hangs out on his and it's not easy being
a diva people always think you're making
crazy demands so it's time to do some
mini myth-busting do you have your own
entrance music when you enter the
restaurant please say yes oh that story
that they wrote no actually is a great
restaurant here called Aurora wood yes
if one of my favorite places it in the
world and they have their own playlist
because I've been there so many times
and it's like a letter pictures with the
owners and things like that so bate
somebody there made a playlist of my
songs that I like better than the
playlist that I have and I was there and
I was like can we get this one the other
one was do you like to have your own
wine flowing in from friends for your
special restaurants Wow sure yeah we do
that every day that's how it is no
better than that's wine cooler I have to
have my wife alone please don't believe
it
one thing we do know Mariah's twins
Munroe and Moroccan they're just as Posh
as she is last time we talked in Paris
too I said mom and you corrected me and
said mommy cuz they call me mummy said
Ashley with an English accent okay mom a
a then an order call me mama mama
Mariah's hard at work back in the studio
recording a new album with longtime
producer Jermaine Dupri including new
music she'll be performing at her
Caesars Palace residency Jesus so what
I've done is I brought the Isle of Capri
to Vegas and it's just fantastic we
thought it was possible but I didn't
we're also excited about her
long-awaited guest spot on Empire
reuniting her with her precious director
and close friend Lee Daniels Mariah's
working on new music for her episode in
which she plays kitty
mega-superstar the major question that
will come from the loans is this hmm
is the part going to be if you got
Mariah in Selma I carry it's not proud
of my role in precious Wibbly you know
No so we're somewhere in the middle I
had a couple conversations and I think
she's gonna be pretty glamorous but um
no see see